stuck at home no III GameSpot's got you
covered we've put together a new kind of
event called play for all it combines
the best of e3 with a month-long charity
drive so you can get excited about
gaming and help raise money for a great
cause at the same time the fun kicks off
on June 1st and we'll be going for over
a month during this time you'll get
in-depth news and press conference
coverage as it happens along with
immediate reactions to the latest
breaking announcements and expert
analysis from the team here at GameSpot
will also be interviewing developers of
the biggest upcoming games and speaking
to the gaming execs charting the course
for the future so you'll be in the know
about all the exciting things on the
horizon more importantly you'll get to
see the inside of everyone's house like
you were being sensible and self
isolating but we figured out ways to
bring you previews of the latest games
using internet magic and far too many
video capture devices will be checking
out brand new games and letting you know
what we think of them of course it
wouldn't be a gaming event without an
exclusive so don't worry we've lined up
a few of those too if that wasn't enough
we're gonna have daily charity streams
to raise money for health care workers
that are battling the kovat 19 outbreak
from 12 p.m. to 2 p.m. Pt every day
you'll be able to tune into gamespot.com
YouTube twitch Twitter and Facebook to
watch everything from live quizzes and
Let's Plays to speedruns
we've brought in our friends from across
the industry to get involved so expect
to see folks like Greg Miller the Giant
Bomb crew Troy Baker the cast of apex
legends and Assassin's Creed origins a
lot of Pierce hey Zeus here's toast
Danny O'Dwyer Naomi Kyle what's good
games and many many more faces and
voices that you know and love so head on
over to GameSpot calm to see the full
play full schedule and don't forget to
subscribe to our twitch and youtube
channels so you don't miss out and we'll
see you on june 1st
you